[Music]
the artist from will get residency here
in Las Vegas how is Ludacris in
Cáceres informative consumption of induction
in Spanish I tell you that the singer of the
moment will present her show
entitled weekends with the TEO
weekend at the SISCAL coliseum on the
21st  from January to mid-April and
it is already known that his tickets will be
quite popular so
the public is being asked to register
beforehand to be able to buy tickets for
more details visit ineos.com and perhaps
al's residence also contributes to the
Las Vegas tourism because according to the
most recent figures since the pandemic began,
the number of passengers traveling
through McCarran International Airport
increased by 10% in October, that is
four million more people than the
previous month, however despite the fact that
more  people are traveling to Las Vegas
since the pandemic began, the numbers are
still not at the level they were
in 2019
and if it is  You are looking for a job. I tell you
that a rival has set up
a job fair. This will take
place on Wednesday at 3:00 p.m. at the
farmhouse.
National rodeo finals competition
returns to Las Vegas and 15 of the world's best
riders will walk the
red carpet at the Sauz tonight the grandchildren will
compete for over $1,000,000
during the competition which kicks off
Thursday and runs through December 11
at the  snack and before closing we take
a look at the temperatures as
we can see here on your screen
we will be in the high 70's for this
Tuesday with blue skies and a
fairly sunny day temperatures higher
than normal for this season as we
will soon feel the cold  of winter
I am Cristian Casseres with his
informative cousin of Is Now in Spanish Buendía
[Music]